if i told you that you were 103 pages
and less than two hours away from
improving your speaking skills would you
believe me well keep watching today
we're going to talk about a short but
excellent book that will immediately
supercharge your speaking skills in a
foreign language hey friends welcome
back to my channel for those who don't
know me yet i am luca apariello a
language coach who speaks 14 languages
on this channel i help people learn
foreign languages more efficiently
faster and in a fun way
confess to it ever since you decided to
learn a foreign language you've been
looking for that quick fix you know that
shortcut that thing that gets you fluent
faster it's not just you everybody's
looking for the same thing that's why
everywhere you look you can find tips
and methods to learn language in a year
a month a week a day and even in a
matter of hours and minutes
i hate to be the party pooper but let me
tell you straight away that these magic
pills do not exist if you start learning
a language tomorrow you will still be
learning it by next weekend next
february and the next time halley's
comment passes by unless of course you
choose not to maintain it so you can't
improve your knowledge of a language
immediately that is out of reach but if
you're looking for ways to improve your
foreign language skills immediately
those my friends are quite easily
available
and you can put them to use in your life
much much faster than you think thanks
to a little book called how to improve
your foreign language immediately by
boris chet
before we dig into our review of the
book let me present a simple metaphor
clothes i have them you have them we all
have them right now at this exact moment
in time you have a finite amount of
clothing that is yours to use as you
wish
unless you want to wear all of your
clothing at once you need a place to
store it all one option would be to keep
them all in a pile you know a big
tangled mess of socks sweaters scarves
t-shirts and tank tops all gathered
together in one corner of your bedroom
another option would be to separate and
organize it all you can hang the shirts
scarves and tank tops in your closet and
fold the scarves and pair the socks for
safekeeping deep in your dresser drawers
you can even organize each individual
item by color or season in which you
wear it
now i'm sure you'll agree that in both
scenarios you have the same amount of
clothing having a closet does not make
clothes magically appear or disappear
but let me ask you this
if i gave you 10 seconds to find a
specific pair of socks in which scenario
would you be most likely to succeed
the second of course having
organizational tools like a closet or
set of drawers will give you a higher
chance of being able to find and use the
clothes you need exactly when you need
them this is exactly what how to improve
your foreign language immediately
provides
it doesn't teach you nouns doesn't teach
you adjectives politeness forms or how
to better use the subjunctive mood
instead it gives you a set of seven
intuitive tools to help you organize and
make better use of the knowledge you
already have no matter how miniscule or
expansive that knowledge may be the book
in short teaches you how to use language
effectively
let's dig into our review
how to improve your foreign language
immediately by boris shetland is a print
book the most current edition of which
was released in 2013. the book a short
read of 103 pages is divided into nine
separate chapters one introductory
chapter seven body chapters and an
epilogue
each of the seven body chapters is
devoted to a particular communicative
tool in the other's own words
communicative tools are the combination
of skills which allow a speaker to use
most effectively the level of foreign
language in his or her command
the chapters dedicated to these
effective speaking strategies generally
contain the following a description of
the tool an example of the tool in
practice typically through a
hypothetical conversation between a
foreign speaker and a native an analysis
of the example or examples and an
exercise through which to practice the
tool in addition sprinkled throughout
the book are a series of anecdotes
personal stories taken from shekman's
experiences teaching russian to english
speakers either one-on-one or in small
groups
and in classroom settings considering
that 75 percent of the short simple book
is devoted solely to teaching you to use
those tools right away you get a lot of
value in a compact inexpensive package
of course none of that information would
matter if the tools weren't so useful
and intuitive each tool can be
immediately put to use in one of three
specific areas quantity quality of
communication show your stuff and build
up your islands communication in
difficult scenarios shifting gears
simplify simplify and breaking away and
increasing expressiveness of language
embellish it and say what these areas
are ones that all language learners seek
to improve regardless of target language
and target language proficiency as
bizarre as it seems as you read up on
each of shekman's seven tools you will
immediately understand how will make you
a better speaker of your target language
how can that be because knowingly or not
you've already used these tools to
communicate better in your own native
language you may even use several or all
of them every single day
think about it have you ever told a joke
so many times to so many people that by
the up teeth telling you know exactly
what words what pauses what intonation
and what facial expressions to get the
maximum number of laughs from your
audience that joke according to shatman
is a well-practiced island that has been
built up and refined according to tool
number two build your islands have you
ever been chatting with a new group of
people when all of a sudden
talk shifts to
a subject you know nothing about instead
of pretending you know about a field you
clearly do not you use some
conversational kung fu to coax the topic
of conversation towards some common
ground so you can resume speaking freely
again the act of definitely changing the
topic when you're out of your
conversational depth is what scheckman
would call shifting gears and is the
third tool that the book provides
have you ever tried to explain a
difficult concept to a friend or family
member and despite your efforts you've
been completely unsuccessful
instead of giving up however you choose
to simplify your words and phrasing and
you try again simplifying complex
language is an example of scheckman's
fourth tool simplify simplify and is
just as useful amongst native speakers
at as it is between natives and
foreigners you see what i mean you don't
have to have tried out all of these
tools in a language learning context to
know that they will help you communicate
better because in the end they're not
language learning tools they're
communication tools and no matter how
old you are if you're reading this
you've done enough communication already
to have an intuitive feel for what works
and what doesn't work all of shakman's
seven tools have this intuitive quality
as far as i'm concerned i've been using
a lot the island part and i normally
build islands that i work and rework for
each island i build a set of 30
sentences and i practice with my tutor
and then i write everything into my
notebook and review the sentences
occasionally i practice them in real
life they come quite in handy
with the advice in the book you have
everything you need to communicate your
current level navigate difficult
conversations with natives and speak in
a more fluid natural way given the
book's short compact form these tools
are easy to practice and review on the
fly i highly recommend this book to any
learner of any language at any level of
skill in terms of actionable skills this
book provides most bang for its buck of
any language learning book on the market
i only wish that the book were of higher
quality with more substantial references
and background material so here's my
suggestion for you guys get the book
check link in the description box read
it in a week it's short but you might
want to use it as a guide underline the
parts that are relevant and interesting
for you make a list of activities you
want to try apply what you have learned
the best way to learn is to do not just
read and last but not least jot down in
a nice lengthy comment below
about your experience your thoughts
about the book what worked and what
didn't doing and sharing are the best
ways to stay motivated and take things
to the next level as always thanks for
watching and see you in the next video
[Music]
you